[Applause]
what's up guys we're for infinity it's
time for another episode of challenge
continuity
[Music]
let's try to hit the mouth stuff with a
ping-pong ball okay the first player to
set off both mousetraps wins
yes yes so we have launched our own
mobile game and as we mentioned turtle
it's a surprise at score 100 so the
challenge is to get there let's do it
so the idea of the game is to get as
many shots in as possible
[Music]
you can hit harder with the longest wipe
it's good to use one hand to move and
harder to hit
it helps you if you topple click into
the shot and hit harder so the ball
comes slower back to you a robot too
robust quite hard we really like to game
so make sure to download for free on
apple and android and try to beat the
high scores ok we are ready for some
double decker ping pong let's try it out
[Music]
[Music]
no two balls at the same time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on let's try playing with an
umbrella
I don't know what parts are hit with
maybe it may be the top part yeah this
part is good no too late
[Music]
no umbrella number two only with the
push of the button I was expecting do
like signs break maybe no around the net
for after this time well it was fun as
long as the flash did but I still think
you can use this they didn't really
survive the playing but don't forget to
hit subscribe and watch our previous
video there until next time